salut à tous ça doit encore brad est la
march madness 2022 donc émission
spéciale évidemment du côté de
d'envergure et pour ça on pouvait
inviter personne d'autre que midnight en
comme poche et donc hugo qui est avec
nous bienvenue lugos salut alex et salut
a tous un ravi d'être avec vous pour
parler du meilleur moment de l'année l'a
donc la march madness fait un grand
plaisir de connaître avec toi elle
plaisir partagé une halte en compost on
appelle un site à fouiller puisque c'est
hyper riches surtout les contenus qui
concerne le sport université en général
pas que le basket football aussi mondes
d'autres sports un peu moins populaire
en france type la crosse aux autres
qu'on peut qu'on peut lire sur 1000
comme peuvent
donc la march madness 2022 tout le monde
ne connaît pas dire tout le monde
connaît surtout aux fans de basket
connaissent à peu près la nba peut-être
le championnat de betclic élite là aussi
c'est un fonctionnement très particulier
donc hugo ce que tu peux expliquer
combien il ya des équipes pour la march
madness et comment elle se qualifie
alors donc déjà ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la march madness c'est
exclusivement expression a sacré bordel
en fait donc pour pour faire clair il ya
350 équipes en première division
universitaire et donc au moins de mars
il y en a 68 qui vont se croiser le fer
pour le titre de champion national alors
donc comment on se qualifie c'est déjà
une bonne question parce que même les
amas même les spécialistes de 1,6 de blé
sont parfois pas d'accord sur sur la
qualification de certaines équipes donc
c'est une très bonne question alors il
faut savoir qu'à 32 équipes qui sont
automatiquement qualifiés en gagnant
leur conférence c'est ce qu'on appelle
les automobiles tout simplement donc
chaque vainqueur de conférence est
obligatoirement qualifier au tournoi de
volley sauf cette année une petite
exception c'est bonnard mind donc dans
conférence eijssen puisque en fait ils
sont
en 1re division depuis seulement deux
ans or le règlement ainsi des baux les
interdits les équipes qui ont moins de
quatre ans en 1re division
interdit la participation de ses équipes
au tournoi donc b normal ne doit laisser
sa place au vainqueur de la saison
régulière donc texte du vide state donc
ça c'est la seule exception sinon les 32
vainqueur de conférences sont la march
madness et après pour les pour les 36
autres places c'est le comité de
sélection qui attribue les billets pour
la march madness donc ça se fait selon
plusieurs critères
d'abord les résultats tout simplement
donc les résultats ça prend plusieurs
critères en comptant au sein même de ce
critère là donc il ya la difficulté du
calendrier parce qu en gros basiquement
c'est pas comme les play-offs nba on va
prendre les huit meilleurs bilans de la
conférence n'a en fait on va pas
s'attacher uniquement au bilan on va
prendre le bilan par rapport aux
aux adversaires rencontrés aussi à la
localisation des matchs savoir si ils
ont joué des adversaires forts à
domicile ou à l'extérieur est également
on va prendre plusieurs statistiques
importantes en compte comme par exemple
le kent pomme a créé par ken pommereuil
chi chi une stat que beaucoup utilisent
pas beaucoup d'amateurs utilisent pour
pour analyser les matches donc c'est une
une des unes des stades qui est pris en
compte par le comité de sélection
c'est ça et donc il ya en fait des bouts
bas toute l'année déjà sur le classement
des équipes puisque tout le monde ne
joue pas le même adversaire quoi c'est
pas la nba avec un calendrier défini
comme tu disais etc
et encore plus quand arrive le moment
qui est arrivé dimanche on appelle le
sélectionne des lots dimanche où il
révélé le tableau final dont celui que
vous connaissez celui que vous avez à
remplir on vous conseille d'ailleurs
peut-être pour la deuxième partie de
prendre à côté de vous pour avoir la
vision de comment ça se passe mais voilà
le sélectionneur sait quand on dévoile
toutes les équipes qui participent à la
march madness et donc il ya forcément
qui sont laissés de côté et qui va
peut-être aurait pas dû l'être en tout
cas selon certains parce que j'étais en
forme
voilà on a l'exemple par exemple de
texas guillaume cette année une défaite
qui a été laissé de côté par le comité
de sélection est qui et qui pourtant est
allé en demi finale de son tournoi de
conférences en sc et c'est une des
conférences les plus fortes sont entrés
dans le détail donc pour
maintenant qu'on sait pas comment on
choisit entre guillemets les
sélectionnés comment se déroule autour
et noir go 1 go il faut gagner six
matches pour être champion c'est ça doc
six ou sept pour les pour les quelques
équipes qui sont moi qui se feront dans
le phosphore est alors beau jeu on va
parler de ça parce qu'en fait tourner en
groupe pour la majorité des gens louent
la march madness va commencer samedi
samedi avec tous les matchs en même
temps et c'est
la grande diffusion à la télé et tout
mais ça commence enfin et mais ça
commence au deuxième tour en fait grand
public et à vendre un premier tour
préliminaire donc qu'est-ce que ça ça
s'appelle le farceur et ça serait jody
vendredi c'est ça donc en fait huit
équipes qui sont dans leur sport donc il
ya quatre matches sur deux jours
donc cette année ça se discutera dayton
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote jeunes c'est
comme ça mais mais voilà donc il ya
quatre matchs donc c'est des équipes qui
qui était en fait en ballottage donc
elles vont s'affronter en un tour
supplémentaire et après le rendement
tournoi au 2e tour comme tu l'as dit
face à un adversaire qui est déjà défini
donc en fait le tour pour être clair il
ya soixante équipes bon je suis très
mauvais en math donc que je fais je pète
pas tiré les chiffres mais il ya
beaucoup d'équipés qui connaissent leurs
adversaires sauf quatre d'entre elles
qui vont découvrir leur adversaire jeudi
vendredi donc on voit ça c'est ça donne
généralement se faire ce faire deux
matches qui sont des plus petites
frappes qui sont des
s'il 16 a expliqué le système décide
après mais cette somme est un c'est le
maximum et puis on ad'autres cédé 11 ou
12 donc là par exemple moi je pense que
même notre dame notre dame va faire
partie du fer ce faire il va jouer
contre google et il ya également un très
bon blog the man in diana diana king
chaque coachée par mike goodson pour
ceux qui suivent la dalle a oublié
expliquons du coup ce système donc on a
le tableau de la march madness les
soixante huit équipes du coup mais à
partir de samedi ce sera 60 4 comment ça
fonctionne justement ces sites de 1 à 16
comment ça se divise aussi puisque c'est
un tableau qui est divisé en quatre du
coup comme tu l'as dit donc il ya 16 6
dans fait par région le tableau se
définit en quatre régions donc
par par zone géographique en fait tout
simplement et donc il ya une tête de
série par région donc cette année on a
par exemple arizona gonzaga et cetera
donc les meilleurs ont ainsi douanes et
donc elle affronte le site 16 de leur
région donc et ainsi de suite donc le
deuxième va rencontrer le 15e de 3e 14e
et c est justement donc pour après
arriver au final fort il faut simplement
gagner sa région donc pour pour être
champion national qui doit sortir de ta
région et après ben les meilleurs de
chaque région s'affrontent dans ce qu'on
appelle le final fort c'est ça c'est ça
après les régions sont plus ou moins
géographique par exemple on a le duke et
en caroline du nord qui va être dans la
région ouest c'est ça c'est parce qu'en
fait les sides à l'époque de série c'est
tout simplement les quatre meilleures
équipes selon le comité durant l'année
donc parfois duc les quatre équipes sont
plus ou moins de la même région en a qui
se retrouve dans d'autres régions etc
c'est ça mais en fait il faut savoir que
c'est très très difficile pour le comité
de sélection de dresser enfin ce tableau
en fonction des la géographie parce que
même nous par exemple si on n'atteint un
tel poste ont cessé à faire de la brèque
éthologie mais après boc pour pour faire
un vrai bracket avec les zones
géographiques c'est juste un enfer donc
honnêtement ils font au mieux bon
parfois il ya quelques incohérences mais
globalement c'est quand même plutôt bien
tenu comme come back and we généralement
il ya quelques effectivement quelques
points discutables mais dans l'ensemble
ça va donc
on va parler juste des favoris puisque
on a dit décide un sont censés être les
meilleures équipes donc là on a décidé
on a cité les sites nous a rapidement
mais qu'on vous montre en tête à ceux
qui nous regardent les favoris dont on
va commencer par le généralement
commence par regarder le tableau à
gauche et donc là c'est le cid un
général puisqu'il était le premier du
classement total et donc c'est gonzague
ragots et logique logique ben pour ma
part je vais pas me cacher c'est mon
favori aussi
après gonzague ans on connaît un camp de
cinq ans chaque année c'est le favori
pour beaucoup et malheureusement pour
l'instant y'a pas de titre à gonzaga
paradoxalement en début de saison
j'aurais peut-être dit que c'était
l'année où enfin rapport à ces dernières
années j'attendais un peu moins grande
saga et
paradoxalement c'est je pense vu aussi
au niveau des autres favoris c'est
peut-être l'année où ils sont vraiment
le plus de chances de gagner
donc très très ouverte
deux grands favoris qui se détache
gonzague à des numéros un général avec
peut-être le numéro un de la draft 2022
dans ses rangs frais mode vidéo demain
avec alan pour parler des stars mais
donc chez tong rennes joue à gonzaga au
cidre outils mais il ya aussi johan
strauss heures et plein de très très
bons joueurs du côté de gonzaga si vous
allez regarder leur roster
le safe et là c'est peut-être un peu
plus une surprise en seed 1 arizona hugo
alors arizona moi je vais pas être très
objectif parce que en fait c'est
justement on peut faire un lien et
gonzague a parce que c'est tommy l'oeil
de qui est passée être coach l'ancien
assistant de maxxium à gonzaga est en
fait un réseau n'a cette année c'est
juste un régal niveau au niveau jeu
s'ajouteraient collective ça joue vite
franchement c'est c'est une très très
belle équipe à voir jouer donc j'espère
qu'ils iront loin juste parce qu'en fait
chaque matin c'est un pur régal donc
donc voila apres c arizona c'est paris
c'est une ils ont eu des bons des bons
résultats début de au début des années
2000 mais depuis ces universités qui a
un peu tendance à ce choc assez souvent
on le rappelle qu'à menacer aux
universités si dwan qui était battu par
un site 16 donc sa classe quand même une
fac mais
a riposté virginio oui
non c'était aussi tout du coin du court
il
voit du coup je me trompe peut se
confondre les deux mais non mais ouais
c'est universités qui
souvent en mars donc quand même enfin se
retrouve face à un mur un march madness
j'espère en tout cas cette année que ça
ira mieux avec notamment ben mathurin
qui
je me régale équipe très internationale
ça va peut-être qu aucune des équipes
favorites des suiveurs européen
puisqu'il ya bail à la crise a alors
laissé il s'est blessé à la cheville
mais il devrait il devrait pouvoir tenir
sa place y passa les deux premiers tours
en estonien tube all is un lituanien on
a tous marre au balo en malien on à
bonnes mature et un canadien on a down
abalain français donc on a beaucoup de
joueurs internationaux
du côté de bari zone a donc ça c'est un
des les autres favoris numéro un de la
région south où l'on cite deux et
vilanova c'est une équipe il ya beaucoup
de joueurs qui sont nba et c'est une
équipe peut-être une équipe qui a les
meilleurs résultats
au global en six ans et dix dernières
années
et j'avais oublié le site de de la
région ghost mais c'est très très fort
puisque c'est duke avec un cinq majeur
quasiment qui pourrait être au premier
tour de la prochaine
dont paolo gontero qui lui aussi prévu
dans le top 3 comme chez tom grain on va
descendre région est hélas c'est le
champion en titre simplement qui est si
numéro un hugo c baylor
c'est ça dès lors pas pareil qu'on
attendait pas forcément début de saison
avec beaucoup de départs on a vu les
notamment les trois gars de stars de
l'équipe de l'an passé jared butler
match au tig et des viandes mitchell
donc c'est une équipe qui a deux
deux gros prospects bon je vais te
laisse en parler mieux que moi après mes
mais voilà qu'il ya deux de gros
prospects à suivre et qui qui s'appuie
aussi sur un meneur transfert donc james
akin jo qui vient d'arizona auparavant
il était aussi à georgetown sous les
ordres de pat chewing mais voilà dès
lors c'est une équipe que
personnellement j'attendais pas je pense
le suédois n'est mérité meilleure saison
maintenant c'est une équipe qui je ne
vois pas aller au bout personnellement
après c'est que mon avis donc
des résultats en dents de scie aussi la
deuxième partie de saison dont c'était
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient moins
dominants que l'année dernière quand ils
ont quand ils ont gagné le titre
national après tout quand même très bien
coachée il faut le dire
que drew est un super coach
effectivement contrairement dit là
certains à john filippi qui est le coach
du site d'auch de cette région au niveau
de kentucky qui est une équipe
dangereuse mais peut-être un petit peu
plus cette année que les dernières
années
puisqu'on a le transfert aux cartes chez
boeing qui donnons lui complètement le
rebond offensif etc et puis un
prospect et washington donc du côté de
kon tiki abeilles leur les deux grosses
pas à suivre on en reparlera dans la
prochaine vidéo mais c'est kendall brown
et jérémy se ramasser ces crises au
chant ça s'écrit sundi soran ensuite je
devais passe rapidement non pas pour les
trolls et mais pour qu'on avance un
petit peu le dernier favori banque seed
1 c'est un sas pour la région midwest
quand ça ce cas aussi un historique de
ne jamais vraiment arriver au bout
malgré malgré des effectifs qui sont
souvent assez pléthorique nous lidoire
de kansas et un senior que vous devriez
retrouver en nba l'année prochaine au
tchaï acb agit vraiment très très très
très complet à lol et très beau mines
ans cette année et le site doute de
cette nous doive c'est encore une équipe
avec un top prospects attendu dans le
top 3 c o byrne ou déjà barry smith
devrait on espère pour eux d'aller nom
d'allah pour les favoris
et ensuite on laisse rapidement parler
hugo quand même de haut niveau de la
diffusion comment ça se passe au niveau
des dates
et comment on fait pour regarder quand
on est en france est ce que tu peux nous
donner des solutions alors en france on
a le player et espionne qui a les droits
internationaux
sinon il ya d'autres moyens que je
n'aborderai pas mais mais bon vous vous
comprendrez
et il me sens que bobines sport va
diffuser quelques matchs ainsi on a
toujours un match par jour
royal globine sport va diffuser pour les
fans de nba voilà où vous pouvez aussi
avoir de la réussite de blessés temps
sans prendre d'abonnement particulier
c'est toujours très très bien une bonne
nouvelle pour le basket absolument puis
connaissant la qualité de programmation
ça devrait être normalement des grosses
affiches auquel vous devriez avoir droit
du côté de bin on va passer à la
deuxième partie
de cette émission on vous expliquer
comment ça marchait la march madness
vous ai donné les favoris maintenant ce
qui est amusant quand même surtout
c'est faire un petit bracket c'est de
remplir son bracket d'essayer de deviner
qui va aller au bout et c'est
et donc on essaye de donner de conseil
solis non plus c'est pas pour toi hugo
jamais jamais gagner malheureusement
alors je crois que personne dans
l'histoire on n'a jamais de toute façon
une raquette tout juste si je me trompe
pas c'est aux dernières nouvelles en
tout cas c'est ce que je pensais aussi
avant d'enregistrer
ses ça donc c'est c'est très très
difficile évidemment d'avoir toujours
mais il ya des concours et des points
attribués et un concours qu'on a lancé
vous pouvez aller sur spillane taper
tournament challenge et vous allez sur
le groupe d'un de
ces fameux bras clubs français je les
appelais où on va on va tout jouer entre
francophones donc avec les jonathan
campos avec les gens du first in dub inc
vous prenez ce braquet pour le garder on
va essayer de vous donner les conseils
hugo conseil numéro un qu'est ce que tu
donnerais pour repenser conseil numéro
un
on sait qu'il ya toujours des obsèques à
la march madness donc des obsèques
de dire ce qu'ils gagnent contre le sait
tout des trucs comme ça et c'est donc
une tête de série moins importants qui
bat une tête de série plus importante
malgré tout même si on a par exemple
l'année dernière où j'ai trouvé que la
grèce s'est battu on est quand même
beaucoup de daube cette eau notamment
premier tour
faut pas jouer trop parce que ok il ya
toujours la tentation de se dire ouais
cette équipe peut le faire et serra mais
souvent l'équipe en question elle ne
fait pas donc donc voilà tenté à au
deuxième set ont vraiment des trucs que
vous sentez vous ressentez depuis assez
longtemps par exemple je vais vous
donner un exemple cette année moi je
pense que je vais jouer vers monte au
premier tour parce que c'est une équipe
que je trouve très agréable à voir jouer
ce groupe tout comme ça qui m'a assez
déçu cette saison donc pour moi c'est un
obsède qui est totalement jouable
donc voilà c'est un obsède que je
tenterai j'entends très peut-être un
autre mais faut pas tenter d obscène sur
tous les matches brackett parfait en
tout cas c'est ça et surtout par exemple
les matches un conte 16 on m'a dit tout
à l'heure c'est arrivé une seule fois
dans l'histoire que le cese gagner et
les deux conteuses je crois que c'est
arrivé peut-être cette fois ci fois
c'est vraiment outre arables et après
quand on arrive à 3 contre 14 la
probabilité commencent à augmenter un
petit peu
généralement ce que je peux donner comme
conseille aussi s'est choisie c'est bien
surtout les équipes que vous mettez dans
l'autre finale fort parce qu'en fait
plus les tours passent plus le monde
équipe que vous avez de bonnes rapporte
2 points donc en gros généralement celui
qui gagne le tournoi alors là c'est pas
un conseil pour mac est parfait mais
celui qui gagne le tournoi du
dans son groupe de racket c'est suis
qu'à l'autre plus de bons résultats au
final force ici vous avez trois des
quatre bonnes équipes au final fort
c'est bien ça veut dire que vous avez de
bonnes chances de gagner si vous si
votre équipe que vous avez une finale
fort elle se est ce qu'elle se pète au
2e tour au troisième tour généralement
ces airs un peu cuites pour vous donc
choisissez bien vous pouvez le faire
dans les deux sens soit vous commencez à
faire les pronostics en parrain et
ensuite vous arrivez avec un final fort
soit vous choisissez direct vos quatre
équipes que vous voyez au fight for et
vous faites votre tableau en fonction
lorsque tu as un autre conseil
un autre conseil je dirais on le disait
en rigolant hors antenne mais ne pas
mettre par exemple des universités qui
quittent chocs souvent par exemple quand
ça kentucky et crh pense que il vous
faut y mettre fin à une forme et est
encore conseil toi je ne conseille pas
mais non sinon il ya beaucoup de
conseils par exemple je parlais du kent
pomme tout à l'heure
c'est c'est très très bien pour remplir
les bracket justement parce que en plus
il donne les clés de chaque match est
donc vous pouvez analyser ça prendre vos
décisions et cetera mais sur le site de
cannes femmes comment tu fais ouais
ouais
aussi bien de pommes bon après c'est pas
vrai il ya des abonnements mais vous
pouvez la voir de façon voilà
vous pouvez l'on vous pouvez le trouver
je vous dis pas où ça peut se trouver
voilà et donc
éviter d'être
trop aventureux jeu bien choisir son
talent fort je dirais dernier conseil
éviter d'être trop classique non plus ne
mettez pas les 4 6 1 au final faire et
aucun obsède c'est normalement pas comme
ça que vous avez remporté votre votre
bras quoique non plus
et j'ai envie de dire surtout cette
année où on l'a dit c'est assez ouvert
je pense notamment à la partie avec avec
kansas est en berne moi personnellement
c'est pas des équipes que je voi au
final fort donc je pense que là c'est
une partie de tableau qui peut être très
très ouverte avec des décide 4,5 même
même si ceux qui
peuvent tirer leur épingle du jeu alors
justement pour continuer dans les
conseils on va parler décide d ranking
qui sont un peu surcoté et donc qui
pourrait se faire piéger ça ça peut être
des bons conseils qu'on a donné aussi
alarmant
aussi beaux les directs les deux plus
forts 6,2 selon moi
c'est duke assez largement le plus fort
et
nous deuxième
j'hésite un peu je dirais plutôt de
villanova puisque
villanova c'est quand même une équipe
qui est ultra bien coaché généralement à
la march madness ça ça fonctionne bien
mais bien coacher est ce que tu t'es
d'accord mois sur les sites de chasse
est d'accord avec toi et vilanova oui
c'est je pense que la plus avec leurs
joueurs comme comme gillespie il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'équipés qui vont vouloir
prendre villanova donc c'est ainsi 2
mais c'est quasiment incident quand on
connaît le pedigree de du programme
c'est ça est ce que tu as des sites 3
qui te paraissent un peu fébrile
fébrile bas tennessee qui est simon 3-6
je dis pas de bêtises tennessee 6 3
ils viennent de remporter le tournoi
je pense qui justement ils sont 6 3
grâce à ça mais sur la saison
honnêtement je les ai pas trouvés
flamboyant est loin de là et en plus il
ya kennedy sienne globe je pense que
vous en parlez aussi dans dans votre
vidéo prospects mais qui est un meneur
de jeu
honnêtement chaque fois que je le vois
je suis assez pour pas dire déçu
je suis assez circonspect en fait sur
son cas parce que c'est un bon joueur il
ya du talent etc mais pour mener une
équipe à la victoire c'est pas le
bonheur que je choisirais mon club
intéressant que tu dis ça parce que
moi la recette que j'ai pour la recette
pour gagner la march madness c'est une
grosse défense et nos arrières capables
de scorer pour moi c'est ça c'est
généralement le vainqueur il a ça il a
des arrières qui sont capables d'amener
du score une même dans des situations
difficiles et il a une défense
collective très très fort exactement
bailar l'année dernière c'était vraiment
la recette
parfaite pour remporter le titre et donc
les équipes qui se base sur l'honneur un
peu moins expérimentés genre premières
années ou qui se base sur un jeu
intérieur en intérieur un peu fort ça
peut voir jouer des tours parce que
bahia il ya un match où ça va pas
marcher quoi alors que l'arrière qui
arrive à se créer son espace uniquement
il y arrive à peu près comme tout le
monde à l'époque qui avait yukon qui
avait réussi à aller au bout avec
shabazz me pierre est juste une bonne
défense alors qu'il n'est pas une super
équipe par exemple donc donc voilà
décide quatre des six quatre mois donc
toi tu avais arkansas vacances a
honnêtement c'est c'est pareil cette
année c'est une bonne équipe
mais de là à voir un side car je pense
que c'est c'est un peu j'ai pas dire
abusé mais
j'ai du mal avec ce site 4 et en plus
ils tombent dans le vermont qui est
peut-être une des équipes les plus
fortes pas un des skippers
ou alors c'est un grosse lipper pour moi
donc j'ai très très peur pour la console
alors moi j'ai pas été impressionné par
donc providence ils ont gagné quasiment
tout le match serré cette année dont
j'éviterais de travailler contre eux
quand même c'est une équipe très
expérimentée
qui en a d'autres comme si le cap du
ciel et j'éviterai vraiment de lui
contre l'homme qui très très solide et
je pense qu'ils auraient pu largement
abside 3 s'ils n'ont pas eu des
résultats ultra régulier mais c'est de
les expérimenter extérieur perdre en
demi finale l'année dernière et ils ont
la même équipe cette année
donc c'est quand même très costaud et il
voit unis illinois des noirs je trouve
ça pas et il se retrouve avec un site 4
parce qu'ils ont eu d un calendrier
comme peut-être un peu moins difficile
que les autres dans leur conférence et
du coup et puis des victoires en début
de saison assez assez cool ouais voilà
c'est une équipe qui n'y a pas non plus
de grosses parts et je me méfie des
équipes qu'on pas de gros scoreur comme
ça ils ont un très bon meneur très sympa
à voir jouer qu'un vrai que rebello ils
ont une copie cockburn à l'intérieur qui
est très très dominant très très gros
monsieur mais voilà c'était pas
forcément
le site quatre ans qu'elle kim inspirait
le plus confiance est ce que tu as des
cinq ou six qui
qui t'inspire justement de la crainte
qui pourrait se faire aux obsèques et là
ça arrive vraiment un peu plus souvent
50,12 généralement il y en a un qui peur
au moins et six contre 11 un an et demi
voire de quoi alors c'est pas en fait
c'est je vais dire yukon mais pas parce
que yukon me paraît faible ou ne crée
pas mais parce qu'ils jouent new mexico
state qui est aussi une équipe que je
trouve plutôt bonne donc
je n'y vois pas non plus faire l'obsède
parce que je pense que yukon est quand
même assez solide mais ça arrive ça
risque d'être un match très bas quand
même très très serré
et ouais c c'est peut-être le site five
que qui est le plus en difficulté pour
moi parce qu'après il ya 5 mai risque
par exemple car un site file chez nathan
deakes ainsi de beaucoup plus bas mais
c'est une vraie équipe 5 mais reese est
justement pour moi c'est possible si
ennemis majeurs qui doit aller faire un
gros run orbi gonzaga ne compte plus
quand une maison maintenant mais bien
sûr les petits plus petites conférences
c'est ça mais est ce si s'il ya une
équipe qui doit voilà tirer son épingle
du jeu et faire un gros run je mettrais
bien simple mairie justement donc
intéressant donc voilà pour ça va
falloir probablement se coltiner ucla
dès le deuxième match donc ça va être le
test
très très gros match en tout cas syrie
est nôtre après on peut parler aussi des
équipes en forme
très rapidement parce qu'il ya des
équipes en fait qu'ils sont sur une
pente ascendante au niveau de la forme
pas forcément un site très très bas mais
qui aurait peut-être si la saison
continuer à grimper au niveau des
classements et du coup on aurait pu même
peut-être enfin en tout cas moi je me
base pas mal là dessus sur les résultats
des derniers mois puisque c'est c'est
important de regarder aussi les séries
en cours et la confiance avec laquelle
arrive l'équipe est donc
l'évidence pour moi c'est quand même
l'équipe qui a gagné le tournoi de la
n66 qui était peut-être qu est l une des
meilleures conférences
cette saison et c'est virginia tech
il ya battu quasiment tous les plus
beaux l'anc a battu duke en finale qui a
battu j'ai pu leur parcours ils ont
battu que les grosses équipes au tournoi
de heads ici et là il se retrouve avec
seulement incident 11 et 20 jeunes au
texas qui est ainsi ce qui n'est pas
extraordinaire
donc je me dis que virginia tech vue là
la dynamique pourrait être une des
belles surprises même si au deuxième
tour il ya potentiellement purdue
qui se présente perdu ou qui quand même
une équipe là aussi très bien coachée
avec des stars à l'arrière et
potentiellement une bonne défense des
shooteurs qui n'était pas facile facile
à jouer
mais pourquoi pas donc il ya cette
équipe est ce que tu as une équipe en
forme particulièrement de ton côté une
équipe qui est sur la pente ascendante
justement on en parlait aussi en
exactement trentaine en fait j'en ai
deux j'ai quand même le yacht chicago
qui a fait un début de saison plutôt bon
ça il faut un bon début de saison mais
quand on connaît le l'envergure du
programme quand même sans mauvais jeu de
mots
j'en connais bien le programme ces
dernières années on pouvait s'attendre à
mieux même si le départ du coach
pourtant mother pour oklahoma
bon ils font une fin de saison
très solide également retour notre
conférence aussi si je dis pas de
bêtises on voit là il arrive en forme et
encore une fois on sait que eux en mars
il faut vaut mieux pas les croisés quand
encore on parle de bonne défense légale
à chicago c'est souvent une des
meilleures du pays donc donc voilà donc
c'est une équipe très forte et on en
parlait ensemble by the state alors
c'est un peu comme comme gonzaga en fait
je c'est une équipe que j'attendais
énormément l'année dernière il y avait
un roster on n'est pas en celui de
l'année dernière je trouvais beaucoup
plus fort sur le papier que celui de
cette année mais en fait dans le fond de
jeu j'ai l'impression que le travail de
l'année dernière commence à porter ses
fruits vraiment cette année où le
programme fait une saison historique
pour le pur boisé state il remporte le
tournoi de la mountain west et surtout
bayaà bouki gab je vais faire un geste
une petite aparté sur ce joueur parce
que quand même il faut signaler une
chose avec lui c'est que partout où il
passe il gagne il était avec l'équipe du
canada je crois que c'est en u18 de
mémoire il bâtit mieux et c'est ta
génération draineront dembar des attié
barrette n'a bon il ya passé origone
l'équipe gagné mes nuits jouais pas trop
donc on va le mettre de côté hélas
depuis qu'il arrive et un bassiste et ça
fait deux ans et demi parce qu'il arrive
en cours d'année le programme commence à
gagner des matches alors que bree states
est pas réputé pour être un programme de
basket
donc voilà la brigade sacré joueur et là
je pense que pour son dernier tournoi il
va avoir à coeur de faire de belles
choses j'ai pris beaucoup même s'ils
prennent zago au deuxième tour équipe
expérimentée est donc temps le conseil
c'est de miser sur eux face à memphis
une équipe avec des gros prospects qui
n'a pas forcément été régulière dans le
jeu même s'il ya eu du mieux sur la fin
de saison donc attention quand même un
peu un fils et a notamment déjà l'oeil
d'irene à l'intérieur qui vaut ultra
dominant qui sera à coup sûr ou presque
à la draft 2022 et donc nous parlera
dans notre prochaine vidéo
est un symbole fort hugo alors je vais
dire gonzague heures
bon je vais quand même être arizona dans
la région sud
dans le midwest j'ai commis encore une
fois c'est le plus ouvert
je vais
qui est ce que je pourrais tenter je
veux pas mettre ici même si j'ai le
maillot actuellement et que je suis un
gros fan boy je vais peut-être tentés
ayo qui viendront le tournoi de la big
ten woippy qui joue plutôt bien je pense
qu'ils peuvent taper providence au
deuxième tour moi je mettrais à gauche
mais bon il vont battre contre ça c est
ça va rouler et dans la partie est je
vais jouer la grosse cote aussi j'aime
être fier ouais
voilà je n'aime pas parler compte uc et
les ondes et des scoreurs de partout
superbe équipe j'attendais mieux de
cette année donc basse et je pense que
c'est le moment pour éclore en mars
c'est une belle équipe pour pour le ton
bon bah écoutes je pense que j'ai eu si
elle est aussi
je pense que j'ai eu ici et là j'ai with
consignes
g duke et arizona reid joue que pour la
dernière de coaching est au flottement
la duke labatut gonzaga pendant la
saison assez vrai sens en début de
saison après c'est un début de saison
n'est justement il avait des traits
chemin etc et ils ont jamais vraiment
beau couple a dû après ils ont fait un
parcours très facile puisqu'ils peuvent
avoir texas tech peut voir michigan
state et le deuxième pour texas tech au
troisième
mais voilà je pense après vous avez
encore un parcours
normalement très facile jusque jusqu'aux
halles élite eight jusqu'à 10 ou qu
autant ciellement donc donc on zagol
favori mais je mettrais duke de
boutavent voilà merci hugo s commerciaux
est-ce que tu as tu a un mois pour faire
la promotion du net ans comme je suis
pas ce que vous avez prévu comme contenu
pour suivre la march madness bah je vais
en profiter oui j'ai que tu m'as tu m'en
donnes opportunité donc déjà las dans
les prochains jours on va sortir
beaucoup comme j'ai envie de dire un peu
comme vous fin non parce que nous on
parlera pas vraiment de prospects dont
on parlera de joueurs à suivre plutôt
dans les mines mesure justement ça sera
bon complément je pense à votre vidéo
vous parlez des principaux prospects et
on va également sortir parce qu'on aime
bien faire à chaque march madness donc
pour pour trouver un peu les cendrillons
pour les cendrillons c'est justement ces
ses équipes de mines d'or sera de
conférence un peu sous cotées qui vont
arriver qu'ils vont faire un run on peut
penser à l'oeil à chicago justement en
2018 toi
par exemple est george mason en 2006 qui
est pour moi la plus belle histoire de
cendrillon donc voilà on va on va
s'attaquer à ça et sinon pendant le
pendant la march madness eaux froides et
live tweet normalement tous les jours ci
si tout va bien et on après on sera
également dépendants de l'actualité pour
revenir sur sur les forces en présence
est évidemment absolument donc boudina
atteindre comme post le site et vous
pouvez les suivre sur twitter pour avoir
vraiment tout ce qui se passe
quasi en temps réel pendant pendant la
march madness
donc nous on n'est pas dans les
commentaires on regarde on doit déjà dit
c'est difficile car il ya tout à chaque
fois qu'on fait un truc sur l'acier les
jeux où est-ce qu'on peut regarder on
peut regarder le match sur les
lesbiennes player ou bien trouver des
moyens par soi-même pour regarder le
match je précise que la plupart de gros
matchs sont en replay sur youtube mais
je ne vais pas donner le nom de la
chaîne sinon elle va disparaître
l'essai mais c'est plutôt on en a parlé
récemment sur sur twitter si vous
descendez notre fils ilia draft dans
voilà donc généralement cédé replay
complexe vous pouvez regarder le matin
c'est plutôt pas mal si vous n'avez pas
envie de rester éveillé la mouche noire
symbo merci à toi pour l'habitation et
je le souhaite tout le meilleur ayew
aussi
ça va être quand même un peu compliqué
en mai
je pense qu'on passera miami mais après
bon o'byrne eux ça peut être une
une adresse à un adversaire quand même
très très coriace une partie de plaisir
et une douce et sucrée l'équipe du frère
moblie pour pour ceux qui n'ont pas
suivi evans mobilité là bas l'année
dernière elle son grand frère qui joue
encore et qui est un très bon joueur ici
et
donc moi pour ma part évidemment vous
l'avez vu j'espère que notre belle il
passera son tour de qualification sont
force force à sa rigueur ce serait déjà
pas mal et ensuite et ensuite eh bien on
verra ça alabama potentiel dit merci
merci à vous de nous avoir regardé on se
retrouve demain vidéo avec alain guillou
pour parler des prospects à suivre sur
cette march madness si on a plein et n'a
peut-être jamais eu autant dans des
grosses équipes donc on devrait avoir
beaucoup de matches intéressants à
regarder